ceci n'est pas un bol de carottes
fraîchement sortis de la terre il s'agit
plutôt de salsifis un légume racine
anciens presque oubliée pour chez bull
et cette année on a choisi le salsifis
moi c'est un légume que j'adore c'est un
légume que qui est facile à travailler
pic qui bon free qui est bon glacé avec
un jus de viande
arnaud marchand participent à
l'opération gardien de semences à
l'instar d'une cinquantaine d'autres
chefs aux épiciers du québec
il a choisi de mettre en valeur en
légumes rares ou ancestral dans ses
assiettes
il a été jumelé à un semencier qui
fournit les graines et un maraîcher qui
fait pousser les légumes
son voeu c'est que cedraschi la
biodiversité dans l'incroyable dans les
produits qu'on trouve en épicerie en
choisissant le salsifis le chef marchand
fait le pari que le légume rave le sera
de moins en moins les gens à force de
découvrir à la dent cette assiette ce
salsifis qu'il y ait du québec que les
gens achevé c'est d'en retrouver je vais
essayer d'en acheter et ensuite on sait
très bien que c'est toujours la loi de
l'offre et la demande
avant de mettre en valeur le légume il
faut d'abord produire les semences c'est
ce à quoi sa sphère julie ross depuis
son atelier du bas-saint-laurent gardin
semences c'est comme un peu la star
academy pour les légumes râpés anciens
ça lui permet dans le fond de revivre à
travers ce programme là parce que ça
fait le lien entre les semenciers les
maraîchers les chefs mais aussi les
consommateurs et sont une dizaine de
semenciers à avoir bâti un catalogue de
semences pour le programme notre
patrimoine de semences et s'amenuisent
d'année en année en fait au québec comme
partout dans le monde ça c'est dû à
notre agriculture le conventionnel plus
de production de masse tomates petit
moineau qqu'un melon rutabaga forte ou
encore salsifis des dizaines de fruits
et légumes les connu pourraient bien
faire leur apparition dans les assiettes
des québécois si les gardiens de
semences remplissent leur mission
et si marie moments brillants radio
canada